foreign
[Music]
Louisiana I grew up in Crowley by
Lafayette between Lafayette and Lake
Charles
Southern Louisiana yeah in Louisiana you
know I've been in New Orleans Baton
Rouge
Lafayette
I stay in all of them New Orleans Baton
Rouge Lafayette what was your childhood
like what was your family like growing
up
well I got
two other brothers and a sister
and my mom you know but
me and my mom really didn't get along so
I choose the street life
you know my daddy got killed and Crowley
so I took to the street like here
I started selling drugs
though
but I seen I had a taste
I had a certain taste
I had a skill you what you could call it
I had a skill on pimping
you know I see I always say you know it
was easy for me to get a woman attention
so I branched out that area
but not before in the area of doing that
my mom had moved to Houston
I went out there and ended up catching
attempt to murder charge
so at 16 I was in Texas prison
I went through
six years and nine months flat in Texas
prison
and
you know it
I was already a Gangster Disciple so you
know
it was different in Texas it was real
you know [__] about their business out
there but you know I'm about my business
so it it went how I went you know
I did my time I stood on all tenure
and I came out there [__] saying well
I went in that [__] but the whole thing
about it when I came out of there you
know
I was a monster
you know
I lost my sister while I was locked up
she got killed
so all I had was me
and my thoughts
you know
I was dealing with me
so my mama kind of
kind of [__] up because my sister got
killed in a car wreck with my mama
driving
you know and I got a brother in the
wheelchair
you know or older brother here in the
wheelchair Mama take care of him and
[__] here and so
it kind of [__] up I just got killed
how's your father die my father got
killed on a drug business in Crowley
like at seven o'clock in the morning
so you know
I kind of resent him for a minute
because he he [__] my life up you know
about him leaving me like that yeah
he [__] my life up but at the same
token I wouldn't be the [__] I have the
day without them them scars you know
some people say they understand
gangsters but do they really
I don't think they really understand us
you know you got a lot of people in the
world wanting to be like us yeah but
this ain't no game like
the years I spent incarceration you know
I did time in Texas prison Arkansas
prison I just went flat in Louisiana
prison 30 days ago I'm fresh out
now I'm out here in California
you know
seeing what my dream is you heard me
but you know because my profession is
you know
all off a [__] you know what I'm saying
I'm used to you know AOE I'm used to
getting it all off the [__] I mean but
right now you know I don't feel like
I want to see what's going on first
I want to see if my life's gonna take a
turn for the better for another another
skill I have a map may go you know what
I'm saying right now I'm just getting my
feet wet because
you know life big and I won't I want my
I feel like the world owe me
I ain't never been around I've been a
stand-up [__]
every time I went to prison I did my
time
still don't know 10. [__] ain't never
did me nothing Never Had Me Like no
[__] or not
you know
but
you gotta see man I think
and the way you pay attention to
Arkansas man you know shout out to
Arkansas everybody
y'all know about that though man you and
you enter that type of life well you
know
you're a person in the making progress
you know you're into that
you might want to take artists out mine
Arkansas always like that's some [__]
that's some [__] the world ain't ready
for that's some unseen footage right
that's the [__] California supposed to
be an old man you know
Arkansas got him moving and grooving man
for real money you catch up right
Memphis Arkansas and Louisiana man
that's where it's at man that's the
pipeline and you go further north Texas
you can't forget a man you can't forget
about Texas man H-Town man that's why I
put my first [__] at my facts manufacts
facts I remember that when I filmed my
first [__] my first black [__] I
remember that I was real well [__] I was
in my 20s like I said I've been locked
up you know what I'm saying I was like
20 20 23 24. what have you done when I
got out what have you done time for
[__] you know
I slang that line
you know I'm gonna be honest with you
know some situations you know here and
there was you know some [__] [__] up
with you know is Costco's behind your
actions
you know where I grew up at you don't do
certain [__] you don't say certain [__]
you know a [__] put your own backlog
for a while you heard me they're gonna
let you chill out for a minute come
steal your Christmas
two three years down the line you heard
me so you know [__] be [__] up in
society not knowing that it's
consequences you know they got all these
little [__] I tell you know like I say
I'm I come home from prison I don't play
that old school [__] yeah I got some age
on me but [__] I'm still with it [__]
I'm up I'm up on it I'm up on everything
I'm watching and seeing everything Ain't
No [__] catching me slipping about
nothing you hear me I know these [__]
catching me slipping on nothing you
heard me I'm tuned in everything so I
know a little [__] got their little
[__] going on I salute you
I ain't gonna get in your ways because
you know what I'm saying my Lane
treacherous you're getting this Lane you
really got to be
you got to be a a big dog in the game
[__] know I'm telling the truth
you got to be a big dog in the game to
watch for when I'm coming
so you know I try to you know stay in my
little lanes because you know life about
going higher you know
crime ain't paying depending on what
type of crime you're doing
you see what I'm saying
see I'm on this growth development so I
be trying to go to the top me I ain't
lying I refuse to be at the bottom I
refuse to be anything but a step loud
none of that [__] I'm not gonna be none
of that
I'm gonna beat somebody in life I am
somebody matter of fact [__] being
somebody I am somebody I might as a king
Maserati be exact
you know what I'm saying so you know
y'all I mean the world gonna stay tuned
you know like I said it's been 30 some
days
you know the best is yet to come but I'm
but I'm gonna I'm gonna take my time
with it I ain't no fool I ain't gonna
move
bad
because [__] cheating [__] out their
position these days
discreet's cheating people at their
from the government on down cheating
y'all cheating us at our position
they're taking away the royalty because
when you got all these raw Kings locked
up
we stay out the way they have more money
for themselves
because you got some dudes in prison
some powerful soldiers some powerful
gangsters some power for Kings because I
just love us to this [__] everybody
ain't no King
that's a goddamn lie everybody's not no
King
but you got some powerful people that
can play some powerful positions but
they're incarcerated you know what I'm
saying and that's where when you mess up
and you got them type of skills
the government gonna hide you in the
type of places
so you know
but says
leaders the ones that do have a voice in
this world you know
let me take our time because
the camera don't never stop
you know you got these scenes like the
word I show you
they gonna give you the deleted versions
they're gonna take out some [__] let you
see what they want you to see that's
what life is people that you see what
they want you to see
they don't let you see what's really
going on okay yeah this person like me
you seen I pulled up yeah I pulled up in
the beam I've been out 30 days I ain't
pulled up walking or nothing I pulled up
me and my girl I pulled up in the Bingo
yeah that proper preparation prevents
poor performance
I refuse to be anything
less than who I am no matter what level
they go on
My Level understanding to this world
is my Clear Vision
you can't fall short no more
that's why I told him I agreed you can't
fall short no more the world could have
been heard my story I got stories
[__] stories I got real Street version
[__]
real Ghetto Stories you heard me I'm
from Louisiana
I've been in on territory I've been a
bad territory I've been in all and I'm
still standing here you heard me
but you what's your greatest strength
paying attention
gotta pay attention man
dude you got to pay attention
you can see [__] six days down the line
and you pay attention because life is
built off patterns
and if you pay attention to them
patterns [__] don't line up then you
might not even realize why [__] going
the way you're going sometimes I used to
question God's Army like say man damn
dude you heard me like why I gotta go
through this [__] why I can't have this
big ass Mansion I know I gravitate the
money I know money man I'm a money
magnet that [__] gonna come here but why
I gotta go spend these times in prison
why I can't be like the next
[__] and stay free but then two
I get a slap in the face like damn [__]
you ain't them
if you trying to worry about they start
who the [__] on right choice
you going through this [__] because it's
the purpose this will go I put it at you
Herman
this way is that you heard me for real
I'm telling you it's real you heard me
that's that's the way it is facts
nothing else period that's what it is
and that's how I see light that's how I
play this [__] that's why I agree to
come here and [__] right but I got a
story do I got a story
prison raised me different states
going in these things getting lost in
the prison system coming out years later
you know the experience the
incarceration dealing with the fake ass
police officers you know what I'm saying
Breaking [__] in the penitentiary I
did it all
relationships all that [__] all the
penitentials [__] that that's when
I'm yes
man [__] know that [__]
look at it they know what's up with me
bringing cell phones drugs all that [__]
to the penitential that's me
that's why the world still see me on
Facebook why I'm locked up all them
years yeah I'm Gonna Keep a cell phone
keep the drugs I'm Gonna Keep Me a [__]
you heard me
so you're even tempting while you're in
prison man [__] listen man see see
that's I see
my first be giving the wrong thing and
be having a peas mixed up
see I'm just a person in the making
progress I'm not the I'm phone ring on
the truth phone ring on the truth I'm
just a person in the making progress I'm
not with the fun they had the funny
clothes it ain't even about pipping off
a [__] I'm pimping off Society
as long as I see long as I see fit and
I'm winning man [__] what's going on I'm
winning
I'm winning you can pimp a [__] with a
job
as long as she's showing proper
preparation the best performing right
you see what I'm saying and the money
gonna be right because at the end of the
day the numbers is where it's at
you ain't gonna go nowhere around that
there the numbers is where it's at and
I've been knowing numbers since I was
young I may not be good a lot of [__]
God damn it but I understand them damn
numbers and I understand if you pay
attention
that's why she's always go back to pay
attention you see what I told you right
it always go back to pay attention
a [__] and see like a
[__] asked me one time it was
like man uh
who taught you the game
and I sit back and I thought about it
I thought about the ogs and Crowley I
thought about the big homies and [__]
enforcement I thought about the [__] in
Texas
but then I looked at this [__]
and I'm like [__] [__]
ain't nobody taught me [__] [__] I just
paid attention
and knew what not to do
you see what I'm saying what the [__]
ain't gave me nothing I just paid
attention and figured out what not to do
what I could do and what I can't do what
you could get away with and what you
can't get away with
so that's why my performance always
being the way it is one thing about me
the world would know one thing about my
own got nothing to hide is really me you
heard me it's really me I'm really yeah
I'm really with that [__] too yeah yeah
I got multiple personality but I'm
really I'm with that [__] too but yeah
I'm a thinker though I can thank I'll be
going to jail for flashing out real rap
real [__] I'd be going to jail for
flashing out I'd be tripping you know
[__] player won't put that line on his
ass yeah
other than that I'll be wanting to live
[__] I want to live like Puff Daddy and
all them [__] too I feel I deserve
that [__] you heard me I feel like I
deserve them rappers and [__] got too
[__] I put in my work too
I've been a soldier of the game
I paid attention
I never stopped going to school hell
[__] I'm still going to school now
the learning don't never stop
I'm drug free I don't do no drugs I
don't do nothing but smoke weed that's
it I don't do nothing else you heard me
I ain't got no time for nothing else
blocking nothing blocking what's going
on nah man I'm focused on this one man
this [__] gonna happen [__] gonna happen
remember that man [__] gonna happen one
day the world gonna know my
[__] name
because I know I paid my [__]
dudes I paid them [__] what would you
look for in a girl
I ain't looking for [__] whatever gonna
whatever meant for me gonna come to me I
ain't looking for [__] man what's gonna
happen gonna happen you heard me just
like the bad [__]
I wasn't looking for that [__] that [__]
happened I did that [__] I went in the
penitentiary you know what I'm saying
still on all 10 you heard me
and came out that busy ass what's up I'm
back in this [__] you heard me
I just paid all type of money right now
all that [__] on record I wasn't
supposed to come on 2025. I just came
home just came from DCI in Louisiana
just went home just discharged on Allen
you heard me Allen Parish in Louisiana
ain't no one toughest printed interest
in there just got stabbed up two months
ago you heard pushing that bag you heard
me [__] from New Orleans was tripping
with me you heard me because I was
pushing it back stabbed me up I heard
you did time for pimping and pendrick
yeah oh yeah I went I went to jail for a
little something on that they held me
for that you know boys
man I don't feel like I I wasn't
tripping and pairing that's the name
they give that [__] I wasn't doing [__]
I ain't do a goddamn thing the [__] I
look like I can't tell a [__] [__] a
[__] gonna do what the [__] want to do
I can't tell that [__] hey [__] go do
that now I ain't that type of [__] [__]
now I ain't on that [__] [__] doing
what she want to do
I was just giving the [__] a ride you
did what I'm saying
but yeah see the pimping see when it
comes down to pimping you got to
understand man
everybody trying to do that [__]
you see what I'm saying everybody trying
to put that [__] on them that [__]
really ain't in the mind
I got a history man I've been beating on
[__] my whole life and I'm not
talking about physical I'm talking about
mentally
I ain't ever had no problem with no
[__] or ever ever
that's why I don't even Fascinate like
that no more okay things I catch more
because I know what's up
I tip my fingers on you heard me
and I done broke some Styles shout out
y'all know what I'm saying I done broke
some some real [__] facts some [__]
they say couldn't be broken huh what
happened I came home put it on you know
what I'm talking about you know what I'm
saying man y'all know the ones that
would be watching y'all know what's up
man y'all know what's up with me man
this [__] for real man this might not be
the last time y'all see me on the camera
man I'm telling y'all man
life is important
and stories is important you might want
to view Minds right
I got [__] to say man I go on and on no
no no I got [__] to say man venues
Avenues wherever you want to hit I've
been up I've been down
I know I feel to be up I know how I feel
to be down but guess what I'm always be
around God damn it what's your attitude
on the
Arrangement you have with your women the
girls does all the work she's risking
her life out there she's she's doing
things that she probably wouldn't be
doing
otherwise but she's bringing you all the
money no no no see you got that [__]
up see a [__] doing what you feel
comfortable doing
see you gotta understand that's that's
the skill
it's not just about the money to a [__]
it shouldn't be just about the money to
the [__]
It's Entertainment
you see what I'm saying
like
that [__] like to [__]
you see what I'm saying if that's what
she choose to do to make a business or
she might be just a good conversating
ass [__] a good pocket snatching ass
[__] whatever the [__] profession in
it all goes in that category right
though
it's a category
also but it's this level to this [__]
see me I ain't ever had a crackhead
[__]
I ain't ever had it I don't I don't I
don't I'm not gonna put that type of
[__] around my Persona you're Hustlers
yeah I got I got to have a [__] that's
sharp I can't have no drug users I'm not
a drug user
you know what I'm saying ever
like I say life built off patterns I
ain't ever been a drug user no smoked me
a little weed yeah I popped me a Molly
before you know what I'm saying the X
before I'm from Louisiana but drugs I
don't do them never did nothing else I
ain't gonna do nothing else you heard me
because I got to protect my temple
and
females are just
females got they
they weighs like men
you know if you study them if you ever
just been around them see it's different
than saying you [__] with a [__] have
you ever been in a room
with a [__] for three days have you
ever been in a car with a [__] and
y'all can't even get the room
the [__] gotta turn the trick to get
the room
but it's cold as [__] outside but y'all
somewhere we all know no [__]
body
you done [__] up at the casino
whatever
whatever phone ain't ringing you know
certain things well maybe not be with
cash not on Deck right now but guess
what we're gonna figure this [__] out
[__] and it's gonna be unspoken I even
have to say nothing to the [__] the
[__] ain't gonna have to say nothing to
me
you see what I'm saying
we need to be done don't get done
you know I
[Music]
a lot of pills might not respect me I
might not respect them but you know what
I'm saying
they lame might be high you know their
goals might be different
it all depends on what you expect to get
out of this lifestyle man
what you expect to get out of it what
you want to get out of it
you see what I'm saying
you might reach your hand and that [__]
and come out that [__] with no fingers
you know how the [__] life's gonna go
bar life [__] up I seen some [__] for
real
you never know what the [__] when you
reach up and now what you gonna grab out
and you might reach up in that [__] and
one night might turn you into a million
now goddamn hot [__] it's on his own
then
in a bit like that been like [__] slow
[__] get a outcall come back
[__] 15 16 bands up [__] you serious
man [__] life to change in a matter of
hour you know what I'm saying so you
know it's exciting in that [__] you know
it's exciting in this [__] don't get it
[__] up it's exciting in that [__]
especially if you know how to manage
money
you know life is excitement
so you wear multiple hats as a girl's
pimp yeah your therapist you're her
manager you have your man I'm the
biggest grandfather your bodyguard
you're everything
I'll play the role of the business model
the [__]
whatever the [__] need
you see what I'm saying
it ain't no certain rules I am him
I'm Jesus see a [__] I tell a
[__] quick [__] a [__] wait on
Jesus all their life and never seen him
[__] you see me
facts you see me [__] live and Living
Color [__] I'm right in front of you
you did
so I mean
for her to get you your money
in a proper way
she got to feel something about you
though
pimp said a long time ago rest in peace
come see my Cry of Louisiana y'all
really know where you're from
he said it man and they could take a
[__] to put in a motel to make money
but you playing with it
now
you send real [__] to jail playing
with this [__]
you know
you'll make a you'll make a straight
hole Goofy
it ain't nothing worse than a goofy
[__] because that [__] don't know
where she going
and the real
a real person with profession stumbled
across this hole and his home make one
goofy move and send you to the feds
then you like damn
this two dollars hold them [__] up
something that smooth so you got to be
careful when you're dealing with these
[__]
you can't trust him
first of all you can't trust no goddamn
body I don't trust you
you know because I know without without
me and you and this here and and and
being involved it will be no
conversation
everything about business
when you talk to your mama if your mama
don't see the light in your eyes
and the flame loses her eyes and you
then she gonna handle you different that
could be your [__] mama
you see what I'm saying
so what the [__] you think about a [__]
a person going to treat you how you
carry yourself once a person lose the
flame in their eyes towards you then
there ain't nothing else to be there
you see what I'm saying ain't nothing
else though you heard me
that's just like the streets
this is good
Kelly got this [__]
you shout out to kill it man they got
this [__] for real
yeah yeah you have any regrets in your
life myself for real you heard me but
say take this out though
yeah [__]
I'ma say this
my regret right here
my baby mama
the relationship I built with my baby
mama I have a child
he made 10 in April
and I was young stupid
I made bad decisions with my baby mama
so it [__] it [__] with my
it [__] with my
my vision with my child
yeah
I regret
making those mistakes
because
that's what kept me alive
when I did want to give up
when because because a [__] talked that
[__] but a [__] reached them loads
a [__] reached them lows though
and when I did want to give up
I paid my own lawyers
I spare real [__] my Mama gave me by
four thousand dollars
but I went back to court every year well
I was down this time in Louisiana I was
back to court every year I brought
myself home on my own but there's plenty
of times I gave when it when it when I
would pay all these thousands of dollars
to get back in according to judge deny
me
I feel the failure my son would have
kept me motivated to get it keep getting
it keep hitting for this sack keep
pulling his prison guard [__] keep
getting these [__] getting this dope
and taking care of his business so I can
get myself out this prison because
nobody gave a [__] about
what was going on but me the only thing
was important was
the world keep going
no matter what the [__] you go through
the world keep going you heard me
[__] still gonna have barbecues
you heard me
[__] still gonna get their
nails and have done
she gonna still go on even if you locked
up you heard me
so
you know
my only regret you asked me that
question that's crazy because you
changed my whole tempo
my regret is my child
it's not being there for my child
because I know
the lack of respect I have for my mom
because of the way I grew up
and made her stay in tune no matter what
is bound
the way I felt when I went to prison
like it's just me though
if nobody care about you
you got to care about you
so I don't want my son to grow up
and feel that [__] like damn man dead I
don't give a [__] that Mama don't want
you to see your child
out that Mama didn't want you to see me
[__] you supposed to fall out of
playing for me [__]
you see what I'm saying like [__] my
mama didn't want you to see me [__] why
you didn't go through a roadblock [__]
drive a plane in the you know [__]
Skydive or something [__] find me [__]
like it's no excuse
but I'ma look up in his face one day and
let him know say something you know
you got a cold ass daddy [__] facts but
you got a cold ass moon and
I swear boy I hate that [__] dog
but I respect her because she raised my
child
I respect her I know she has wonderful
mother she's a [__] as a person
sex but she a wonderful mother I know my
child don't want for [__] that's why I
let it be what it is because a [__]
know I would have been flashed but I'm
like okay man do you you know one day
you're gonna see I'm not that [__] I'm
that [__] everybody say I am I'm him
[__] right [__] I turn to Freddy
Krueger on your ass quick but at the
same time
I deserve more I have my down moments I
have my up moments
you know but
I ain't never cost nobody that didn't
cross me sex
and some [__] you know I let die now
don't mean I forget
yeah
[Music]
I might let some [__] died around here
trees might grow German
[__] like like snow might rain sleeping
everything
Seasons might go around but you never
know
never know
never know though you never know
[Music]
with these days
you see what I'm saying and that's why
I'ma keep it real that's why a lot of my
family be like man with me but I'm real
to those that's real to themselves even
my [__] my [__] no
right now I can have 10 [__] right
now facts
I could put right now on Facebook man
what's up man what's up
Holla At Me
they know how I'm coming [__] where you
want to go [__] I can't go to Paris
[__] I used to be on parole [__] but
I'm not no more [__] was out you heard
me like that okay [__] it was it was
not I'm free
ain't got a [__] traffic ticket I'm
free I do what the [__] I want to do so
right now I'm just sitting back relaxing
enjoying the views you see what I'm
saying
but [__] better stay tuned man
cause I'm coming
I'm coming
baby mama all that you're gonna see me
I'm coming man I've come with the
biggest lawyers for your ass though
facts I bring them lies for your ass I'm
about to take your ass to court I'm
tired playing with you
Mazzy uh pimps are one of the most hated
segments of society yeah tell me about
that no no no no no no no no no no
that's a [__] lie that's a
[__] lie see check this out
pimps are one of the most lovedest
[__] in the world
some [__] just scared to
embrace that
every [__] fantasy is to [__] with us
God made us because because a whole need
a man right on the whole new man
so God made us
and every [__] is old
they just don't know it some of them
don't know it some of them know what
they just don't expose it
but every [__] got a freaking side come
on man
the [__]
it's up to you because you can bring it
out a [__] see that [__] know
I ain't lie man look check this out man
these redhead [__] I hear you know what
I'm saying check this out
you know what I'm saying
yeah right the whole world after this
[__]
man this [__] was my homegirl for years
and years and years and years and years
I'm talking about boy phone ring on the
truth man I ain't lying man phone ring
on the truth man but uh you know this
[__] on the uh I get this [__] right
before I get ready to come home
in 17. I Kissed this [__]
man
I broke this [__] heard me the whole
man I'm talking about [__] that's well
how'd you do this it ain't how I did it
man you know what I'm saying what's
meant for me Gonna Come to Me
that's where any [__] I don't run
around here just running behind no [__]
no man
when they present itself that's what it
is
you know what I'm saying you can only
have a mess up so long they're gonna
understand you freaky if you freaking
you gonna [__]
you see what I'm saying I ain't got to
tell you about hey [__] go [__] this
[__] [__] you can go [__] that [__]
you know that's the right thing to do
what else you ain't doing nothing else
to wasting time
use that little kitty cat fan thing else
you might as well get that stash
you see what I'm saying so that's I mean
so that's why I say y'all be feeling
pimp side bad you know what I'm saying
because
like
me I get seasonal with this [__] you see
what I'm saying
I might go nine months long on the [__]
and then go off six months
you know
everyday life ain't
motels and Hollywood boulevards and Las
Vegas and all that [__] it coming
downsized especially dealing with
[__] when you're dealing with
multiple [__]
you know what I'm saying because I got I
got big names you know big Partners
there's yeah you know what I'm saying
and I and I and I
when I moved from Louisiana to Arkansas
and you know and I seen this [__] in
Fort Smith you know what I'm saying and
I seen like Partners you know that I'm
cool with okay man man this [__] real
man and then check this out real [__] me
and my pimp partner
and uh
I got this red [__] I got this red
Beast that was going to college this
year
so I'm hard on the bench you know what
I'm saying because the [__] wouldn't
listen
you know what I'm saying so that [__]
was like man man say say Darnell bro man
you got to break the [__] man on it he
said man you got the gifts you got the
gifts so to cut that out man you know
what I'm saying I got out and
this little [__] this little black
[__] my first black [__] she had hit
me up
she using her brother though you know
her brother was locked up I was locked
up with her brother in prison she
telling me to bring her some stamps but
it's like 10 o'clock in the morning
so I'm dropping my
I'm dropping somebody child out to
school so I'm like okay let me swing
over here and holler at the beach where
the [__] come straight out like man
come on man I see it in you man come on
let's shoot so I dropped the name I'm
like well you know my partner says you
know him I'm like yeah this is my
partner so she was like man you can't
call them I pull the phone I'm like
[__]
and boom I'm probably like what's that
mg so I'm like running oh the [__]
sitting there so she was like telling me
coming to Houston tell him coming I had
a candy red black man I had a candy red
sedan to build in she like tell me we're
coming to Houston
so lone star shot being a [__] after
Houston you know it's one of the swallow
but you know I got a feel of it and then
if I see how fast this [__] coming you
heard me and it [__] my head up at
first cause I'm like man
[__] this [__] ain't nothing else more
important
been paying attention
you see what I'm saying they always go
back to pay attention you understand
ain't nothing more important
so I kept it going
and kept it going and no matter how much
you run from this [__] this [__] run
back to you
facts just knowing you got the gifts
to make you happy were you born with
that gift
see Manny she got to be in me I ain't
reading no [__] books
like I said and and then what that's the
[__] I did pick up on I picked up on you
understand what I'm saying by paying
attention
because that's what's important
you know so like I said you know my
partner's like yeah you know Minds you
hard on the [__] you know what I'm
saying yeah I heard him
I didn't get right to it but then when
it presented Itself by me paying
attention I caught the right signs the
right move and then boom he didn't go
here go to lunch with me
here they go here go me okay damn this
is what I'm good at I'm good at I know
I've been good at it but really I'm
great
and the only thing been stopping me is
these jail gates
you understand what I'm saying
that's the only thing stopped me is
these jail gates
you did
so
I tell everybody out there this
inspiring or looking at this [__] man
understand this [__] like
they said crucial man you gotta know
when to turn that light on I want to
turn that [__] off
because the white people getting golf
ball numbers they're hitting them
[__] and [__] stuck inside them
walls hard to come out them [__]
especially if you ain't gotta
consistent income
see that's important that family-based
[__]
you know
some of y'all don't understand about
y'all people man y'all people in jail
need y'all man
that support system give you more joy
lift your head up
well [__] ain't going right you know
what I'm saying that 50 Cent text might
change your mind frame
[__] already getting treated
like [__]
try eating the bologna sandwich on
Christmas
see how to make your spirit feel
so
you know but they see the hell that I'm
out here now you heard me [__] what's
going on in there I mean shout out to
them boys you know you know Freedom bars
you know I would love for him to [__]
with them you know the institution
because I love institution I give back
now I'm cash happy and all [__] know
what's up
I got a brother in that [__] right now
I cash up and all I take care of it I
thought you heard me [__] know one
thing they can hear myself [__] I'ma
answer
yeah what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
taking my time
won't it too fast
only too fast you know like you see that
light
you see that [__] it's called like the
playoffs it's like being in the playoffs
you see that [__]
you see it
it may not be
right here right there but you see it
you know if you keep paying attention
and staying focused
you're gonna beat up
because you're one of them
you know you got one of these [__] and
you got one of them [__]
you know what I'm saying
I keep everything in that white you know
I'm one of them [__]
for real I'm one of them
so I know what I deserve
I know what the [__] life owe me
you ride your [__] nice car everybody
else taking care of their [__]
business hell I need my cut too you
heard
I need my [__] cut
what's up with me
[__]
I know God kept me up for a reason I
could have been dead
Nick could have killed me 15 000 [__]
times
that ain't what it is [__]
yeah
yeah [__] just bushed me in prison
two months ago stabbed me up
three [__] you heard
cold from your shoulders [__] know
what's up with that
[__] [__] me up look I'm still back
still shaking still straight though that
ain't gonna stop
never stop
so like I said with a [__] you know you
don't know what the future gonna bring
you know you don't know what's going on
I mean I know you might not know what I
know you might not know but I mean
this [__] was rolling in the beginning
like Jesus
you know what I mean I understand that
I understand that every day like man
this [__] was wrote In the Beginning
like Jesus right [__]
your stories wrote like Jesus
see man don't understand that
every day every second every hour your
story is right before you do it
so he's like Jesus [__] you might be I
know I man I'm King majors
[Music]
so
and if I understand that fundamentals in
life
and I succeed
or I watch out
watch out
I deserve it
I deserve that lifestyle bro
facts
yeah
and everything I've been through
sex I deserve it
all right King Mazzy thank you so much
for sharing your story thanks I wish you
a lot of luck man thanks thank you good
luck all right